la science a rarement autant été au
coeur de l'actualité
en soi c'est très bien que les
connaissances scientifiques circulent
davantage
mais dans cette marie d'information se
glissent des discours nom scientifique
est trompeur qui alimente la
désinformation pour ne pas tomber dans
le piège
on doit développer certains réflexes
marie bien avec la pandémie on a vu à
quel point on est pas tous outils et la
même façon pour comprendre la science
c'est facile de tomber dans les pièges
absolument parce que c'est facile aussi
de donner une aura scientifique a pas
mal n'importe quoi en fait qu'on parle
de micropuces vaccinale contrôlé par la
salle g ou du pouvoir des cristaux passé
la docteure langage qui enrobe tout ça
de presque crédibilité mais quand même
quand on veut distinguer sciences de
pseudo science c'est quand même quelques
indices qui ne trompent pas par exemple
l'information qu'on peut considérer
scientifique
c'est le résultat de recherches
sérieuses on peut résumer en gros on
fait une hypothèse on teste cette
hypothèse avec des expériences en
laboratoire et ensuite si cette
hypothèse là est confirmée on n'est pas
encore satisfait parce que il faut aussi
que d'autres scientifique révise les
résultats avant qu'ils soient publiés
dans une revue sérieuse que même à ça
c'est si jamais complètement finie parce
que idéalement on veut que d'autres
équipes reproduisent ces résultats puis
un réflexe qu'on voit beaucoup qu'on
entend beaucoup c'est quand on se dit
ben une telle personne me l'a dit moi je
les ai vécus soi même ou un proche c'est
pas assez pour retrouver quelque chose
de scientifiquement fondées c'est vrai
qu'on l'entend souvent par exemple en
matant tu dis que ce traitement là ça
marche très bien pour elle ou encore ben
moi je regrette je suis un gémeaux à sa
mascotte ma personnalité correspond
parfaitement à ce signe astrologique là
bon tant mieux pour votre temps tant
mieux pour vous mais une expérience pour
que ça ça une quelconque valeur ça doit
être menée sur beaucoup de personnes du
poids de l'expérience d'une seule
personne
justement tu parles d'astrologie
pas dans l'air du temps c'est une somme
qui a qu'un petit engouement dans ce
moment là dessus même si regame
popularité chez les jeunes
bon la première chose je pense que
j'insiste là dessus c'est de savoir
faire la différence entre l'astrologie
et l'astronomie
non vraiment pas piller encore beaucoup
de gens qui confondent les deux les
astronomes mais ils étudient les corps
célestes leur propriété les interactions
entre eux tandis que les astrologues
pense que c'est même corse et laisse là
ont une influence sur notre personnalité
sur notre destin
ça veut dire que tu penses pas que les
astros des fleurs sur ta vie sont encore
mais peut-être un peu écoute la terre
exercions l'attraction gravitationnelle
sur moi mais garde les deux pieds bien
au sol
le soleil me réchauffe ou peu endommagé
ma peau si je mettais pas de crème mais
au-delà de ce nom ça va à l'encontre de
tous les principes scientifiques et
d'ailleurs à chaque fois que des études
rigoureuses et contrôlés sur le sujet
dans de montrer que les astrologues font
pas mieux que le hasard mais ce qu'on
voit aussi depuis le début de la
pandémie il ya tellement d'exemples de
ce ça quel point la désinformation basée
sur la science est souvent doublée d'un
appel aux émotions
oui parce que quand on a pas de faits
solides on dirait que c'est vrai qu'on
va s'en remettre à nos émotions on va
essayer par exemple de susciter
l'indignation en nous disant que le
gouvernement nous cache des choses donc
peut-être ses voeux un conseil à donner
c'est ce qu'a vraiment d'apprendre à
distinguer les sources d'information
fiables de celles qui ne le sont pas ça
tombe bien en une section entière de
notre site web qui est consacrée à ce
sujet là donc je pense que ça vaut la
peine d'aller faire un petit tour pour
s'affûter l'esprit que oui puis de
partager ses connaissances le sénat sans
que ça devienne vieira